hello was that all about you guys you
got a little sprinkling neck cute he's
dressed really well please I guys got
nothing on us come on you're not the
most stylish guys around Vikings also
unique hey call me super shopper and the
clock fuccin can't bring out the show
spring out the racks where's the
dressing room most likely in the back
right on the wall just as I suspect I
your master part shifted more flight
clothes and the overhead compartment
without a v-neck sweater I'm short
[ __ ] her my lesbian chat on boy
periwinkle beautiful pic French cuffs
keep in leather sandal my look is a thug
my hope is often penis will be no box
for the fedora and exfoliate with blood
from Sephora coats down little treats
for coats r in the braking ahead donegal
tweed I'm looking sweeter than the half
cut but surely I'd tomorrow plus for the
red hair got your birth mother daddy
watch my dimples Rumple simple guess my
name when your bag me
feels a little bit like a dance grizzly
bear give you a hug and cry ironic
t-shirt was a joke now Who am I kidding
i'm in the fitting room why is nothing
quite fitting
keep a wallet or how I store my much
less in jumbo size tropical jujubes kids
pull off his hat put it back on the rack
biker who loves are so tight they make
my feelings hurt give me five six of hit
out this cashmere cardigan white linen
slacks and nice until a shard again I
wear women's watches cuz my wrists are
too slender I have a watch pick up the
name is standard morning rakun overcoat
and be singing my jeans a dancing with
this 57 frame I don't like what I see
when I look in this is bad you look muy
Buena I'm the backup and their athletes
body that leaders room always pissing
off pirates cuz i have no boating they
can work with the modeling fashion looks
fun but my mother's is about as straight
as Tim Gunn dirty looks from before when
people notice my thighs even uglier up
close call me Barbara Streisand this
step my parents wanna et phone home
alien head ain't cool I look like a snow
cone I'm not dancing with a passion but
about this fashion salty cuz my salt be
the only thing the stashes when did the
dressing become the depressing
no you're right buddy I love my body so
I got no Buddha